أهمية مبنى مطاعم هاري كاراي ،
كما تعلم ،
تم بناء هذا المبنى في عام 1895 في
قلب نهر الشمال وكان المبنى
بمثابة مركز توزيع الخمور قبل
وأثناء الحظر وبعد ذلك
مباشرة بعد انتهاء الحظر فرانك
نيتي وزوجته أنيت التي عملت
لدى  سيطر آل كابوني على
المبنى وامتلكه على مدار الثلاثين عامًا التالية ،
وكان هناك أنظمة أنفاق تحت الأرض
حيث يمكنهم القدوم والذهاب
تحت الأرض ،
وكان مبنى المحكمة الجنائية في زاوية صغيرة عبر
الشارع حتى تتمكن من النظر من النافذة
ومتابعة ما يحدث.  كان يحدث في
قاعة المحكمة بعد أحد عشر عامًا من
افتتاحنا للمطعم ، وجدنا أنه
غرفة هنا يبلغ طولها 85 قدمًا وسقوف يبلغ ارتفاعها 16 قدمًا
لم نكن نعلم بوجودها حتى
أن كهربائيًا كان يحفر
عبر الجدار وأدركنا أن هناك
شيئًا خلفه
وجدنا دفتر عناوين مدفونًا في
جدار به أرقام
هواتف منزلية لعصابة وأرقام هواتف منزل آلترمان بداخله
وجدوا الخزنة  في الحائط ،
اضطررنا للاقتحام ، لا يوجد مال ، لكنك
تعلم أنه أمر مضحك لأن الناس يواصلون إرسال
الأموال إلينا مثل أموال حقبة الحظر
من الخلف ، ثم يقولون جيدًا أنه لا يوجد أحد
هناك ، لكن دعني أساعدك على مراقبة
رأسك هنا واحتفظ بالمزيد  أصغر في
الأيام الخوالي ، يمكنك رؤية الشارع الذي اعتاد أن
يكون هنا ، اكتشفنا عام 1953 أنهم هدموه بالأرض ،
لكن يمكنك القدوم والذهاب تحت الأرض
هنا ،
وجدنا هذا منذ وقت ليس ببعيد
، إما أنه تم إجهاضه
في النافذة أو  قبر أحاول
الوصول إليه ، لكنه عمل أكثر مما كنت
أتخيله فقط ، ولكن نظرًا لأن هذا
تحت الأرض ، لا أعرف لماذا سيكون
لديهم نافذة هنا ،
ثم لاحظت وجود باب محشو بالقرميد ، يمكنك أن
ترى أن هذا كان  لقد
تم إخراج الطوب وإعادته عدة
مرات مثل معطف خالي من الدسم ، كان أسمنتًا مثل
هذا لبنة مختلفة هنا في الأسفل مما كان عليه في
الأعلى كان مثل الرقعة وقد
تقدمت عائلة فرانك إيدي في
الأشهر الستة الماضية لأن ما فعلته هو ما قلته
إذا وجدت  لا توجد أموال هنا ،
سأشاركها مع عائلة الثمانين المخيفة
بعد ذلك ، أعلم أن أحد أفراد الأسرة المراهقين
تقدموا وتعرفت عليهم جيدًا ،
لذا بدأت في إخراج بعض
الطوب لمحاولة تشغيل منظار داخلي
عبر الجدران  الصندوق الخشبي الذي
وجدته موجود في مكان ما هنا ولكن عندما
بدأت في الدخول ، كان بإمكانك رؤية
حطام الطوب يتساقط منه وأنا
لا أهتم فقط بواحد ، يمكنك
إما أن تكون مالًا أو قد يكون
جسمًا جيدًا كما تعلم أنك لا تفعل  هل تعلم فقط اذهب
إلى هناك لا شيء مقدس ، ماذا لو كان
هناك شيء مخيف يسقط ، لذا فنحن نوعًا ما
نكون منهجيين بشأن نهجنا
لمعرفة ما هو موجود في هذا الجدار ، ثم
هنا كان المدخل الرئيسي
للمبنى الذي كان تحت الأرض يمكنك
ترى في الأيام الخوالي ، لا بد أن لديهم
مظلة هنا لأنك ترى أن
هذا رسم وكان هذا مدخلهم ،
كما تعلم ، أعتقد أن العصابات يمكن أن تأتي
وتنمو وتذهب تحت الأرض من خلال
الأنفاق التي تعرف ربما طرقًا سرية
على الباب وهم  "  د دخول المبنى
[موسيقى]